[Music]
what's going on guys
Netflix they're at it again they're
expanding their little corner of the
Marvel Universe bringing Luke Cage to
the airwaves you saw him in Jessica
Jones now he's getting his own show
what's it about how's it gonna be
well because it's back-to-school month
we're gonna explain it to you in a
segment we call please explain Luke Cage
and we've got a couple of cool comic
heads to talk about it with first she's
one of the co-hosts of Marvel movie news
welcome marki McCarty thanks for having
me house oh thanks for coming nightly
toxin Luke Cage hell yeah
and he is also a co-host of Marvel movie
news and he's a writer actor and
all-around bon vivant the Kois Andra
welcome back hey show them the back man
so tell me Luke Cage why is it one of
these characters that's been beloved for
a long time but you didn't think might
make it I personally didn't think it'd
make it because when I looked him up as
a kid I looked him up because I found
out Nic Cage named himself after Luke
Cage and I whoa
who's this gag and I hadn't heard of it
I'm a pretty big comic fan so when I
looked up a character that I needed to
find out more about and there was this
awesome edgy walking the line between
hero and villain questionable between
all perspectives I didn't think that'd
be the guy we'd get as a major superhero
on a 13 hour show for me it was a well
you only had so many choices when you
were growing up with like actual
characters that you would be able to
relate with yeah so there was Luke Cage
there was Black Panther there was storm
I'm sure you see like the trends uh-huh
so with Luke Cage he was from Harlem
he was this hero that he didn't start
off a hero I would love to hear a little
bit about the origin story for the
uninitiated in the comics how did Luke
Cage get his powers when Luke Cage is a
seagate prison he's part of a failed
experiment he ends up being basically
broiled and a biochemical there's an
actual phrase biochemical Electrical
bath that's right Wow recall the things
that I want to remember so yeah so he's
bathed in a biochemical electrical bath
and because of that he has steel hard
skin Wow yeah in cell regeneration and
that manifested in just that hard
exterior the hard skin but he's not like
unkillable or something
he can be drowned he could be gassed you
can get bone bruises you can get
lacerations under the skin he can still
be injured by erosion yeah we've seen on
Jessica Jones he's gotten shot he's
gotten all sorts of scrapes and he comes
out on skate and it gives him a certain
level of superhuman strength too because
he can regenerate at all time so he's
super strong he's the most durable but
that also causes problems and one of my
favorite storylines are well my favorite
things they do in the comics is when
they haven't get hurt and not be able to
solve it because of the skin so he can't
get stabbed he can't get shot but you
know what he can do he can bone down
with Jessica Jones am i right everybody
so uh does does any of that action
happen in the comics absolutely oh wow
Danielle Cage named after Danny Rand
who's iron fist
now let me ask you this how closely to
the comics is has Jessica Jones and her
relationship to Luke Cage
oh it's well really really on par I
think I think I think it's parallel
because you can't do a lot of it because
basically Jessica Jones goes through a
mental breakdown and just start seeing
whether she can and they they
streamlined it because the important
part of the love story is Luke Cage okay
so we talked about Jessica Jones a
little bit how much does Luke Cage
interact with the other characters in
the current Netflix Universe daredevil
Punisher okay well it seems like what
they're going to do is they're they're
doing something different there's the
defenders for those uninitiated
defenders kind of like a street-level
Avengers is their lack of material
they're like an anti team there are a
team of outsiders I'm kind of a thing I
they deal more with mystical and
supernatural okay like Avengers deals
with huge global tight
intergalactic the funny thing about
Netflix as the defenders and you have to
say Netflix's yes offenders is because
Luke Cage is actually the only one that
was actually part of the defenders right
now yeah and now Netflix has Jessica
Jones daredevil Luke Cage and iron fist
and Punisher he's just gonna remain a
little a lone wolf I think they'll make
him part of it because of how well he
did I think Jon Bernthal made that
happen I think on the forehand it was
like it's a backdoor pilot that turned
into like oh my god what a great part of
the show now he's a defender and they've
kind of shaped the defenders around at
Luke ages relationships and like
retrospect interesting so he's talked a
lot about Luke Cage his posse who is he
opposing does he put heads with kingpin
who else in that universe
right when she goes up against well he
kind of has like a monster of the month
kind of a thing like each issue and when
you actually see this particular thing
that Netflix is doing they have them
going up against Tom Cornell cottonmouth
cottonmouth is a kingpin
like character okay uh he is very suave
but kinda savage says that my tinder
profile suave yet savage hope I'm
important he is a head of odd mob and
it's hem versus Morgan who's another mob
boss gotcha
Luke Cage actually is going after
cottonmouth because cottonmouth has the
evidence that would exonerate Luke Cage
from being you know from when the heroin
was planted on him before so this is the
storyline they're going to be following
in the Netflix show I think I think
they'll have a storyline wherein he has
blackmail and like the freedom to get
him out I think they're definitely gonna
be like he knows that he's innocent and
he has the ability to get amount and I
definitely think they have been rich
history and they've cast two brilliant
actors like Marsh Ollie I think is one
of the best actors working period
playing cop he's playing coach in
Netflix they've been this beautiful
thing where they here on the villain are
as important as each other so if you're
going against my culture you're telling
a story that's so rich and so different
you need an actor that can be the
powerhouse villain you nailed something
right there because that's one of the
things that make the Netflix show so
good and it's a departure from the films
in the MCU because the villains are
often lacking there but kingpin kilgrave
those are quality rich villains there's
nothing that you can get with Netflix
that you got with Jessica Jonesy I'm
going to get what Luke Cage is that you
get to be intimate with these characters
you get to be intimate with the villain
get to know exactly what makes them tick
I mean just the trailers that they've
been putting out with Marechal aioli you
have him standing in front of his Biggie
Smalls painting you know what Roger
Allam
the crime the way that it shot the way
that he is and the lighting and you
already know exactly where he's coming
from and you want to be there the entire
journey with this character wow he likes
when you call him big papa okay another
thing I want to ask you about he's got a
phrase that he would often use in the
comics sweet Christmas it's a magical
thing I think it's one of the best
catchphrases in the history of comics I
shouldn't start off yeah start off a
sweet Christmas
it was sweet sister sweets is sweet
mother haha sweet Christmas and it's
stuck because it's fun to say awesome
so you've really laid it out for us but
I'd love to get your take now on how
this show is going to separate itself
just overall in tone in kind of world
view from daredevil from Jessica Jones
in this Netflix Marvel world
I think musicality I think the the
world-building and I feel like Netflix
has done an amazing thing even with the
trailers even with the five minutes
we've seen of building a world
yes it's dark yes it's gritty yes we've
experienced that Netflix but we're
adding a musicality and an Urbanus and
it doesn't feel contrived doesn't feel
exploitative it feels like a universe
we've never witnessed from his eyes and
we get to see what harlem's like for
someone that lives that side of it not
someone judging it from above for me
with the intimacy that you got for
Jessica Jones not only could women
relate to it because of kilgrave you
know they touched on things like gas
lighting and pressures and everything
that a female deals with they put that
into Jessica Jones with Luke Cage I
expect the same level of intimacy
they're going to deal with race issues
and they're going to put it in a way
that is going to be relatable to
different cultures like I feel like this
could actually kind of start bridging
gaps for people from the fact of their
showrunner they have Chiyo cooker they
have a mainly black writing room it's
like this is this is amazing this is
we've come to this point in time where
we can have Luke Cage and we can do it
right well you guys I brought you here
to please explain Luke Cage and yeah
absolutely did I feel educated about
Luke Cage do you feel educated about
Luke Cage what are you looking forward
to what do you nervous about how do you
feel about the Netflix Marvel Universe
let us know in the comments section
below we want to know
want to thank my awesome panel Marquis
McCarty thank you for making your first
appearance on screen junkies yeah
awesome having you boys and ro thanks
for coming back buddy and I want to
thank you for watching I'm how Rudnik
hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
you've seen them fight as hero versus
hero you've seen them fight as friend
versus friend now the greatest threat to
the Avengers is it's gonna be themselves
again isn't it yeah that's what happens
when your villains kind of suck Captain
America Civil War